hello everyone and welcome to a new
video this video is going to be going
over the story and
ending of cyberpunk 2077. the beginning
we'll be summarizing the story
and how we got to this point on screen
after that everything is going to be
after that screen and all the endings in
cyberpunk i do want to bring up two
important details in regards to these
endings but we'll bring them up when we
get to those parts and i'll let you know
when those come up time stamps are going
to be on screen and on the timeline if
you want to skip to a specific ending
but if you want to watch the whole way
through
let's get started for the story summary
we start out as a mercenary named v
looking to make it to the top we have
three life paths corpo nomad and
streakhead all have their own intro but
all end with us being best friends with
jackie these all converge at the first
mission we do when we save that woman
that was kidnapped and put in the ice
bath we and jackie have the same goal
become legends and make it big our
dreams start to become reality when we
meet the famous fixer dexter deshawn who
asks us to do a job for a client
fixers are the middlemen between mercs
and clients which is why he gives us the
job where to find and obtain a robot
called the flathead and meet a woman
named evelyn parker at lizzie's bar
these two end up being setup missions as
this leads to the big heist of getting
the biochip from kenpecki plaza at the
penthouse floor which is owned by
yorinobo arasaka
sun to the current leader saburo arasaka
the plan fails very fast as yuri nobu
chokes out his own father
and tea bug is discovered in the net and
killed we and jackie wing it and decide
to run
us jackie and the biochip are hurt and
the only way to save the chip from
malfunctioning is to put it in our own
heads as it needs to be in a contained
environment with a specific type of
temperature this leads to a heated
firefight through the hotel
we then escape but jackie doesn't make
it we almost didn't make it if it wasn't
for the chip as dexter puts a bullet in
our brain and dumps us at a landfill
we're then saved by yuri noble's guard
takamura who takes our side in believing
the tragedy that occurred the interlude
with johnny and what victor tells us
provides more context to the story
johnny back in 2023 with the help of
rogue and some friends raided arasaka
tower and detonated a nuclear bomb in
the tower
johnny has always been anti-corpo and
hates all these big tech companies that
rule night city arasaka and militech to
name a couple he thought blowing up the
main headquarters would put a stop to it
he was clearly mistaken as arasaka has
not only recovered but grown since the
tragedy he then tortured jonny and put
his mind in their soul killer program
so cool we have an angry rocker boy in
our head except he's trying to kill us
unintentionally of course obviously
having two people in one body is not
safe for the body and on top of that the
biochip is slowly eating away at our
mind eventually we'll lose our hearing
then our sight
then we die we can see how bad it gets
in game as we constantly have times
where we feign to have seizures or just
cough up blood at random moments so now
the game has gone from trying to be the
top merc in night city
to trying to not die from a piece of
software we're currently scrambling for
ideas
takamura suggests asking lady hanukko's
bodyguard to see laini hanukko herself
takamura believes that if we can get her
attention she'll listen to us
except that backfired so we have to take
some more aggressive means
meanwhile rogue provides us with the
info on helmand the man who created the
chip so if anybody knows how to disable
it it'd be him
hellman sadly won't help us as we have
an experimental untested version of the
chip so he doesn't even know what to do
previous chips were just able to save
pre-made engrams and have conversations
with them this new chip allows the
engram to host a new body this will make
sense in one of the endings later so no
worries if that confuses you as this
specific chip was commissioned by saburo
himself to make matters worse hellman
isn't a part of arasaka anymore so he
can't go back and test these things
either the quest then starts to become
split so it really doesn't matter which
one you take on
we then visit the voodoo boys ignoring
the fact that they tried to kill us and
we enter cyberspace and see the memories
of johnny and all
alts was the creator of soulkiller which
allowed her to flee to the net forever
and leave her body behind which is what
we see in johnny's memories
so real quick to recap what we just
discovered ultimate the soul killer
program
hellman designed the physical biochip
johnny got saved on an engram after he
was captured thanks to the soul killer
program
they made hellmann make the biochip as a
test run to see if their current
experiments would be successful that
experiment was to see if they could make
immortality this experiment was
commissioned by saburo arasaka himself
as it's obvious he's very old and
doesn't have much time left the reason
we need lady hanukko
is because saburo was dead yori noble
would clearly disapprove of our quest
and lady hanukkah was the only one with
enough authority to truly know what
soulkiller is and won't kill us on site
that's how johnny got put in the chip
why he shows up when we put it in and
our reasoning for visiting all these
places throughout the game in cyberspace
all tells us that all the mines that
soulkiller has collected are stored
inside mikoshi
a large server in arasaka tower of
course the only person capable of
telling us how to get into mikoshi is
lady hanako so we stage a kidnapping
during the parade to successfully do
this we need to find the netrunner and
hack into the systems to disable the
alarm so takamura can peacefully talk
with her but that backfires so we gotta
bounce
we then reconvene in a nearby apartment
but that also backfires and we have to
bounce again after some time hanukko
asks for a meeting with us alone
after the meeting we're then at the end
of the game we now come to the five
endings these endings are the arasaka
panam johnny and rogue suicide and
secret ending
the arasaka ending is the default one so
if you did little to no side content
this is your only option available to
you
this ending as you agree with hanako's
plan it's more of a give and take
she shows the board members of arasaka
how terrible their current leader
yorinobu is so that she can take the
throne and we get the surgery so we
don't die
we collapse in an elevator and awaken a
room with scientists this room is on the
spaceship called mikoshi it's actually
possible to see takamura throughout this
ending before we collapse assuming you
saved him in the ambush but
seeing as i honestly didn't notice that
we could even do that he doesn't appear
for me but he could obviously appear for
you
it starts off with simple things like
cognitive and physical stamina test and
it's constant
day after day test after test after test
after test for who knows how long we do
this
one thing i didn't mention though is the
hologram before the elevator scene as
this is relevant now hanako shows us
this twice
i talked before about the current
version of the biochip that hellman made
was more of a digital version of the
person which allowed people to speak
with others who passed away
but that's it since saburo is a digital
engram he has no power even though he's
alive all he can do is talk so he needed
the test version which we
put into our heads which allows him to
actually inhabit a body and we know this
works because johnny can inhabit our
body when we take those pills
for other forms of media for this to
make sense think of the primes from the
recent season of the 100 or pretty much
the entire plot of altered carbon
thanks to us saburo arasaka will never
die he will just inhabit another person
when the body's time is up as while the
body is dead his conscience and soul
isn't allowing him to keep on living and
living with the same memories and
thoughts just a different body
like i said these outside forms of media
are super helpful in explaining the plot
twist ending so if you are slightly
confused i highly recommend them
especially since altered carbon has a
cyberpunk theme to its setting and
can technically be seen as the sequel to
this ending we can see other world
leaders giving their thoughts on this
idea and they are fully disapproving of
it while sabro was explaining that it's
all legal thanks to a ton of legal
loopholes
we are then presented with two options
sad news is we're not gonna live
everything we did was for nothing
hellman who apparently got his job back
offers up a contract to join the secure
your soul program should we sign our
body is now within soul killer this
means our soul and mind is locked up
like johnny's with the promise of being
reborn again in a new body like saburo
should we disagree we are given roughly
six months of life with no chance of
surviving
if we disagree we are sent back to the
earth living our lives until death
v sings a song by samurai called never
fade away which talks about
well never fading away just like the
title we take one last look at earth
knowing everything we did was absolutely
useless and that while we get to go home
we won't be home for very long
if we join we're hooked up to a machine
to begin the secure your soul program
procedure of putting us into soul killer
for us to be reborn later the song never
fade away plays again what we said in
the operating table when these endings
finish
all we get is voicemails from the people
we have met whether they are important
characters like panem and judy or
side people like perales that we may
have never met this is the first
important bit of info i want to talk
about that i mentioned earlier in the
video
while i will be mentioning minor
portions of the voicemails i'll be going
more in depth with these in a future
video as i plan to release a companions
lore video detailing the many
characters we meet in that city like
panam carrie judy johnny river to name a
few i'll bring up more notable
voicemails from time to time in this
video but i'm not gonna dissect
everyone all the time as that will be
saved for a future video and
most aren't too important anyway to
understand the ending but for arasaka's
ending if you don't sign
most of the emails are about people
missing you and wondering where you've
been
if you do accept it's roughly the same
our second endings are with panam this
is only available if you've fully
completed panam's quest lines
we panam and the aldocados join together
to breach through arasaka and find
mikoshi
lots of lives are lost throughout the
way but we ultimately push through and
fight adam smasher he appears as the end
boss in the first three endings arasaka
panem and the rogue ending when we
connect to mikoshi we're given the
choice of keeping our body
or having johnny inhabit it those are
our two choices if we keep the body as v
we get arguably the best ending in the
game where panam and v in the remaining
alta caldos leave night city and find
new life elsewhere
night city isn't really worth our time
anymore and besides we did cause some
major havoc with arasaka so we
definitely need to flee if we want to
make it out alive
if we choose jonny to inhabit our body
we get a whole new ending with him
as v permanently the idea is this one
person goes in cyberspace with alt the
other goes into the body of v
and as we said before the body can't
have two people in it the first option
with us leaving with panam to go to
night city was v
taking control of the body johnny going
to cyberspace this one
is v in cyberspace and johnny taking
control we don't look like johnny
remember as it's still v's body but
we're playing and acting as johnny like
we've done many times about some of the
side missions this shows small moments
with johnny and the neighbor steve
taking him to a local guitar store to
play some silverhand music then visits a
columbarium which is kind of like a
cemetery in 2077 you write the person's
name on a tagline inside the container
and some personal belongings we can see
all the characters that have died that
we have met people like evelyn
jackie and tons more jackie says good
night sweet prince which is a reference
to hamlet by shakespeare where hamlet
dies in horatio's arms in which that
phrase is muttered hamlet dies in
horatio's arms the same way jackie died
in ours which i thought was a really
cool reference
it's definitely recommended to do this
ending if you've done everything so you
can see all the burial sites in game
i also wondered if these boxes have to
do with killing people cd projekt reader
months ago said that the endings of the
game may have to do with how many people
you kill maybe that meant the named
boxes that we see or all the boxes
in general but i'm rambling this ends
with johnny giving v
his bullet charm back and taking a bus
away from night city for the voicemails
especially if we go with panam most are
normally talking about
how our life in the desert is people
like mitch are relevant as they were in
the fight and
saul doesn't appear for obvious reasons
i'm unsure if it's just strictly panam
or because in my game she was my romance
lover but she is super pissed at johnny
for taking v away whereas the opposite
she's talking about being late to camp
as remember we left with her and the
other nomad
so she's been with us the whole time the
third endings have a bit of an
explanation to them but let's get there
first the third is where we agree with
johnny to have him take over and go with
rogue to finish what they started 50
years ago we round up rogue and waylon
and attack arasaka tower again with some
new toys and gear this ending provides
arguably the best weapons to keep after
the credits roll so if you care about
new gear and weapons
maybe you want to do this ending too as
these weapons are really powerful once
again we fight smasher and we see rogue
die but continue to fight with weyland
to defeat him this ending gives us the
same choice as the second one who gets
the body
choosing johnny once again gives us the
previous ending with steve with small
details like giving rogue her gun as a
burial option if we give it back to v
he becomes the legend of night city like
he dreamed but as v
we end up taking on our final mission
from mr blue eyes where we go to space
to assault the blue palace the biggest
casino in the world which is located in
space
truly a ending to our legacy this may be
confusing so let's draw this out
these dependings all depend on two
things who is the host of the body when
we get to this point in the mission
and who gets it at the end of the
mission in ending two we as v
decide who takes the body v or johnny as
we're the ones who inhabit it in the
beginning but in ending three
it's johnny's decision as we let johnny
take over so johnny gets to decide who
gets the body
v or johnny no matter what the
circumstance if jonny inhabits the body
at the end decision we get the ending
with steve
if we play as v and continue in v's body
we get the nomad ending
but if we as johnny choose to give v his
body back we get the previous ending we
just talked about the reason v's endings
aren't the same compared to johnny's is
because of the circumstance
johnny got to be real good friends with
v and also wanted to stay in cyberspace
so no matter what happens
that was his plan for both endings was
to visit his grave for v his goal has
always been the top perk in the
afterlife with panam's ending we don't
get that option as we leave with the
nomads but with rogue we literally
stormed arasaka tower just like it made
johnny a legend 50 years ago it makes us
a legend today
which is why those endings are different
i assume we'd still be a legend in night
city considering in both endings we
storm the tower under different
circumstances but with the one with
panams ending we don't get to see that
praise and fame that comes with it as we
leave the city
minus a few minor things like slightly
different wording the voicemails are
basically the same for both two
and three for ending four we get the
worst ending which is the suicide ending
this is done by selecting one of the
previous three options then choosing the
second guess option of where we just put
it all to rest this gives us the fourth
option of suicide this makes sense as an
ending
every ending we've done somebody dies
rogan saul died a smasher as well as the
others who have died along the way
the other endings this ending stops that
from happening we're dying and it's a
heavy burden to have people die for us
even though it was our fault we're in
this mess in the first place so let's
solve both problems we know we're gonna
die anyway so let's die with having
nobody else die for us
this has johnny and v have a heart to
heart about life before pulling the
trigger and ending his life the
voicemails are tragic
everyone is heartbroken some are even
angry at you judy just getting over the
loss of evelyn
someone who literally killed themselves
not long ago is now witnessing another
friend
do the exact same carrie was majorly
depressed in some of the dialogue that
we find and even considered killing
himself as well so he knows how terrible
it is to do such a thing and is mad at
you for even doing this
like i said some are angry but most are
just paying their respects to you it's a
sad ending and it really shows the
repercussions of suicide
i don't think i don't think you knew
just how many friends you really had
the last ending is the secret one and
the last thing i want to mention in this
video
is that this one is very complex
according to cd projekt red it requires
a certain amount of affinity with johnny
i can't explain what specifically to do
but i will give you two most important
things that either seem to be the only
things that matter for this ending
or the two that are definitely the most
important as affinity could mean
anything is it every conversation with
johnny we've ever had main mission side
mission gig
anything as that could probably take
months for someone to fully understand
it
but the two most important ones i've
found are completing the samurai
storyline which is meeting with rogue to
find him for owen smasher have a date
with her
get the band back together and play one
last gig the other is the gravestone
portion when you in rogue try to find
intel on smasher you visit johnny's
grave you must say the line the guy who
saved my life there's a ton of other
dialogue that may or may not matter but
i followed the guide on rpgsite.net so
shout out to them
if you want to try this for yourself
i'll leave a guide in the description
down below if you want to answer
exactly what me and them said as we both
got the scene to work using this
i noticed the badge at the top with the
samurai logo said 70
a number i didn't know you could reach
as i kept getting 60. so i'm assuming 70
is the minimum to get this i'm not sure
if there's a higher number than 70 yet
as i haven't discovered this but it's
possible
afterwards to trigger this you must
choose the johnny and rogue option
then sit and wait at this screen for
almost 5 minutes
johnny takes the silence as you're
undecided so he offers you an
alternative possibly dying in a blaze of
glory by going right through the front
door of arasaka hq
and doing it yourself it's the most
badass ending as you are literally
soloing a mega corporation
this is easily the hardest mission in
all of cyberpunk every enemy has red
skulls and they all killed me in two
hits on easy difficulty
if you die that's it and it rolls
credits this option and the suicide one
are technically one in the same as you
basically give up your life it was
either by you doing it yourself or dying
to arasaka the voicemails are gonna be
the same
but here's the thing i don't have the
ending if you succeed
actually i don't think anybody on
youtube has the ending at the time of
making this video currently it's been
less than a week since cyberpunk has
been out at the time of making this
a small amount of people have beaten
cyberpunk and even smaller amount of
people have gotten the secret ending
and i would say maybe less than a dozen
people have actually beaten the ending
this isn't a glow but i feel like i'm
the only person on youtube at this
current moment that i've seen so far who
has the footage of the fight i've seen
no videos or screenshots of this mission
at all
the only source i have for the endings
is rpgsite.net once again but this is
without any proof of screenshots or
videos i'm not saying don't believe
these endings but i always like to see
proof to claim that it's real the
endings are essentially the ending three
the rogue option at the end we get to
choose who gets the body
if we choose v we get to become the
legend of the afterlife where we go to
space and attack the casino
if it's johnny we get the stevie ending
again this ending is the same but the
beginning is
massively different as you can already
see look out in the future as i plan to
guard this game to 100
to be able to tackle this quest i was
only level 25 when doing this footage on
screen so i'm hoping by level 50 these
won't be red skull enemies and even if
they
are i'll be well more equipped and
prepared to kill them as i said this is
the hardest mission in cyberpunk as this
is literally a solo raid
just be prepared in the coming weeks
when i'm hopefully able to actually
tackle this and show actual footage of
the choices from this ending
i apologize if you wanted more footage
than something other than the first room
but honestly it's
[ __ ] hard with that we come to the
end of the video let me know your
favorite ending or the ending that you
got in the comments down below
like i said look out for both the secret
ending gameplay and the lore video on
the main characters in the game coming
in the next few days or weeks as those
will both take some time to do
thank you for watching like and
subscribe and all that beautiful stuff
and goodbye
[Music]
you